hey y'all it's andrew couch here and
this tire tuesday video
we're not going to be doing any coding
today instead i wanted to offer five
tips for starting your own data science
projects
so i've definitely been getting some
questions about one how i got a data
scientist position
or how i found jobs in data science or
how i even developed some skills in r
and i and the main answer is i just
started a lot of
side projects in r and i truly think
that
um data science projects or just side
project projects in general
will give you some competitive edge to
other
uh candidates especially if you lack
if you lack some type of experience say
you had an
internship revoked during covid or
you're just trying to find an internship
um my first tip
for uh getting a for starting your own
first data science
project is to choose a topic you're
actually interested in
um if you're gonna spend like 40 to 100
hours
uh coding and working on a data science
project or model
you should at least be very you you
should be interested in it
especially since uh you're putting on
your resume you will
be needing to talk about your projects
a lot uh i know when i was doing a lot
of interviewing
i was constantly talking about
the problems i faced in my projects why
i'd even started these projects and what
it actually does
so choosing a topic you're interested in
is an important
aspect of a data science project and
these topics can range from
a lot of things so on one hand it could
be just you're interested in sports so
you want to do a lot of sports analysis
or sports models
or you could be interested in a specific
data science technique such as like
time series analysis or classification
models
it really doesn't matter as long as you
have some type of interest in what
you're trying to do
my next tip for your data science
projects
is make sure that the data you're using
requires some type of cleaning
or some acquisition process
so with kaggle kaggle has really great
data sets
but kaggle should not be used for your
data science projects to be put on your
resume
is kaggle essentially is like the gym
for data scientists
where you're trying to practice and
strengthen your skills
saying like modeling or computer vision
but
when you're out in the on the field
actually doing it in the applied
workplace your data will be more messy
and will require more cleaning
so with my classification model for the
sorting hat project
most of the data came from a package um
but the data was just the entire
text of the harry potter books to
required a lot of data extraction
where i essentially had to extract all
the dialogue from the books and create
labels for the dialogue
which required a lot of regular
expressions and also use of
engrams additionally i have another side
project
uh called my ufc sports betting model
which required
some data scraping so i was i did some
create some functions to scrape some
ufc fights and ufc data
and that was basically how i created my
data sets for
on my ufc sportsbank model that i'm
working on right now
so one thing that's also good about just
like
having your own data acquisition
functions or data scraping functions is
that
you're really able to understand the
data that you're using and you kind of
get a nice
understanding of like what you're trying
to do and
you talk about it more so
my third tip for starting your own data
science projects
is to make sure the project is easily
understood by hr
um with hr they're gonna be the first
ones reading your actual
resume and they'll be seeing your
projects first
and you always have to consider that hr
is not technical so you should really
try to keep the jargon
at a minimum and have some type of high
level summary so that anyone
who reads it will understand what you're
trying to do for example
one of the main reasons why i created a
harry potter soaring hat model
and not just called it like a nlp text
mining model
nlp text model is because everyone knows
what harry potter is
it's a very popular franchise and people
know what the sorting hat does
so when they read harry potter sorting
hat model
you can understand that it's like some
type of model that will determine
what house you belong to right
and what's interesting about it is that
um
most of the time people when i
interviewed would ask me about the harry
potter soaring hat model
over sweet board because the harry
potter story hat model just seemed more
interesting to people who
aren't interested in data science um
which is one of the reasons why i kind
of regret creating sweetboard
is it it it's a little harder to
understand what this
um dashboard actually does but i mostly
created this
dashboard because i was using it for my
own um work just doing a lot of
twitter text analysis so i decided to
actually
um keep up my resume but i would
definitely recommend
to create a project that's easily
understandable
i was actually watching some videos of
you know side projects for software
engineers
um although it's not directly related to
data science
um a lot of the projects were very
convoluted
where you had to have some type of
computer science knowledge
to get understand what they're doing and
i think that can be detrimental to
a lot of resumes because most of times
it's going to be an hr person reading
your resume first and if they don't
understand it
uh they're just gonna throw it out and
it basically wastes
your time because you spent a lot of
time on the project
and it hurts your job prospects
so my fourth tip is to make sure your
project
has a clear meaning clear relationship
with delivering business value
so creating and doing analysis on
something
is great and all or doing something like
correlation or
uh topic modeling on on a data set is
cool
but you need to have it relate to to
business value
and business value is either increasing
revenue or decreasing costs
so for example a harry potter sorting
hat model when a data science
hiring manager or someone technical sees
it they understand that it's basically
an nlp classification model and nlp
classification models or the harry
potter sorting
model can basically be repackaged to
like
a customer churn model that would read
like uh email feedback right
which is pretty easy to understand how
it could be used in the workplace
um if you just uh tweaked a few things
for sweetboard it's essentially a tool
that could uh speed up the process of
doing text mining or nlp
which can basically uh decrease cost by
increasing efficiency
and productivity among like analysts who
are wanting to study some text data
um finally my last tip for starting your
data science project
is when you actually finish your data
science project you should have it
public somewhere
so for example i would recommend that
you just put it on your github
i think github is basically a gold
standard for data science and software
engineering
so just having your repo or your project
on a repo
is important um one thing i would say is
most of the time they won't actually
look at your code but having your github
account on your resume uh can add some
credibility to it
additionally if they do look at it you
want to make sure that you're
documenting well
and you're you're kind of coding with
some best practices
so it's not just a mess you have some
type of thing that
is organized is understandable and it's
readable to anyone who
wants to see it when you're also
showing your projects i would recommend
having some type of visual component to
it
so for example i have a public tableau
account
and i created a dashboard analyzing the
iowa elections
and this actually landed me an
internship and a fellowship
so having some type of visual component
it's just better in general because
people don't really want to see code
they want to see some type of visual
aspect of it
to get us uh so it's easier to get like
a so what
uh or some type of outcome
um i also
uh have my sweetboard on my shiny apps
so there are a lot of
free services that will allow you to
deploy things online
very quickly um so definitely have that
in mind when you're creating a model is
have some type of present
page for it to present your findings or
at least to add some interactiveness to
it
uh let's see here and i think that's
basically it for today
um i wanted to make a video just on data
science projects i'm a huge
advocate for data science projects and i
think the best thing to do
is just start the project keep these
tips in mind
but it's better to start working on it
first and then kind of tweaking it
um i truly think that data science
projects are all very valuable
if anything you'll be able to learn
something new
and hopefully you'll be able to find a
job so i'll see you guys next week and
tidy on